Leute was war das denn viele viele nachrichten haben mich auf whatsapp erreicht und ja auch für mich war es eines der bewegendsten
Ereignisse meines lebens wir haben gestern, im wahrsten sinne des wortes die nächste stufe der raumfahrt erlebt das war wirklich unglaublich
Und wenn wir heute erfahren dass der chor das
Zentrale element der ersten stufe nicht auf dem spaceport den chip gelandet ist dann ist das nur eine randnotiz
Gestern wurde wirklich die menschheitsgeschichte neu geschrieben und das hat ihnen mass geschafft
Jetzt also alle details und ein paar verblüffende news zum start der fall wie bei kik zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen bei den allen masc chroniken
Etwa aussieht viele landung von falken stufen auf dem space pop duo chip of course a view durch die große hitze
Und dem starken strahl der triebwerke fielen die kameras vor ort schon öfter aus doch dieses mal ist die erste stufe der korb
tatsächlich nicht auf der landeplattform
aufgesetzt nur einmal in 1 d triebwerk hatte gebündelt und so reichte der schub nicht für eine korrekte landung aus die stufen viel ins meer
Und ist verloren aber was soll's das ist wirklich nur noch eine randnotiz eine kleinigkeit was wir gestern erlebt haben ist ein meilenstein
In der menschheitsgeschichte jetzt gibt es zumindest
gefühlt nahezu keine grenzen mehr bemannte raumflüge zum mars und anderen planeten in unserem sonnensystem
Sind jetzt keine hirngespinste mehr die falcon heavy ist aktuell das größte
raumschiff der erde und zeigt als zwischenstufe zum nächstgrößeren schiff wohin die reise geht
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes zahlreiche neuigkeiten gab es dann. Im anschluss von
ihnen muss zuhören und man hätte es sich denken können dabei waren einige verblüffende
informationen das fängt schon mit dem raumanzug des paceman an es ist nicht nur
Irgendeine verkleidung nein im geheimen hatte allen masc einen eigenen smarten und leichten raumanzug entwickelt und gestern hatte er seinen jungfernflug
Edel maas hatte seinen tesla also nicht mit einem höchst verkleideten spaceman ins all geschickt sondern das was wir gestern gesehen haben war
ohne dass wir es ahnen konnten der test eines neuen
alltagstauglichen absolut spektakulären raumanzugs verglichen mit den aktuellen
Klobigen modellen ist auch eher mal so ganz nebenbei ein großer schritt eine bahnbrechende innovation
In der raumfahrt zitat das ist das einzig wahre das sagt mast wir haben drei jahre lang gebraucht um diesen
Welt drauf anzug zu entwerfen man kann einfach in einer vakuumkammer
Springen und es ist in ordnung ja wer genau hinschaut wird zudem etwas ziemlich verrücktes auf dem armaturenbrett des tesla roadsters
Entdecken zumindest beschreibt es so wenn du auf das armaturenbrett
guckst ist da ein kleiner tesla roadster mit einem kleinen spaceman
Erklärt was tatsächlich hat in einem us ein kleines hot wheels auto auf dem armaturenbrett
Befestigt und einen mini paceman herr eingesetzt auf diese idee muss man erst mal kommen
Zitat es ist irgendwie albern ist lustig aber ich denke das alberne und lustige dinge
Wichtig sind ich denke die bilder sind etwas was die leute auf der ganzen welt begeistern wird und das ist auch wohl
So ein um die erde fliegen spaceman in einem tesla roadster
So was habe ich mir wirklich nicht
Evander wildesten fantasie vorstellen können ich bin wirklich absolut hin und weg und es gab weitere
News die dragon kapsel die astronauten ins all fliegen kann ist nahezu fertig zitat wir wollen ende
Des jahres eine kuh in den orbit fliegen sagte maske und auch zur big falken rocket zur, bfh gab es neuigkeiten
macht sagte diez vom
Bfh könnten in diesem jahr auf dem testgelände von spacex in texas beginnen
beginnend mit hopper flügen dabei wird das schiff mehrere kilometer in die atmosphäre geschossen und wieder gelandet
jammers gab keine zeitpläne für möglichen missionen zum mond oder mars bekannt
Aber er sagte dass ein eher tor wird es für die
Bfa erst in drei bis vier jahren geplant sein damit wir kennen es vom mast hat er mal wieder die pläne verschoben die beiden
frachtflüge zum mars bereits
2022 sind damit nicht mehr möglich aber
Was da gestern geschah war absolut mein bloggen und ob das jetzt etwas länger dauert oder nicht das ist glaube ich
Vollkommen egal musk hat den traum der menschheit zur eroberung, des weltraums dem hat er wieder neuen schub gegeben
Ja, im wahrsten sinne des wortes ist es absolut phänomenal und ich werde glaube ich noch ein paar tage gänsehaut haben gleich ist bei euch
Auch so wenn es etwas neues zum thema gibt und damit rechne ich in den nächsten tagen und ihr dazu keine news verpassen
wollt und auch, zu allen anderen themen dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an und natürlich auch nicht das abo vergessen mit der
Genau dann erfahrt ihr also bei whatsapp erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stimmt der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht ich habe es gerade gesagt das aber mit der
Glocke vergessen ist habe ich das einzige wie du mit zwei paukenschlägen also hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken als erster
Staat dafür wie die größte rakete der welt der livestream da bekommt man noch, mal die gänsehaut-momente mit ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran